ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant nous allons prendre la
direction de l'hémicycle du sénat où les
explications de vote du projet de loi de
finances et bien ne devrait plus tarder
les sénateurs doivent en effet se
prononcer sur la première partie du plf
la partie recettes le vote devrait
intervenir d'ici deux heures environ
sauf surprise les sénateurs devraient
rejeter pour la quatrième fois un texte
gouvernemental
on sait déjà que les sénateurs
centristes et ump vont voter contre ce
projet de loi les sénateurs communistes
vont s'abstenir mais du coup et bien la
majorité ps écologistes et radicaux de
gauche ne suffira pas à faire passer ce
texte alors nous allons donc rejoindre
l'hémicycle du sénat pour suivre les
explications de vote mais avant cela est
bien le gouvernement devrait demander
une seconde délibération sur certains
articles qui ont été retoquée par le
sénat notamment l'article 6 qui
concernait la taxation des plus values
des cessions d'entreprises une taxe
dénoncer eux par les entrepreneurs
autoproclamé pigeon tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle et on se retrouve
juste après le vote
je pense que l'amendement a été
distribué l'amendement 442 rectifier il
est présenté par monsieur le ministre
pour le gouvernement
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement du gouvernement et
traditionnelle il est de nature purement
technique puisqu'il prend en compte les
amendements sous amendement voté par le
sénat et tire les conséquences sur
l'équilibré budgétaire dès décision
ainsi prise premièrement il convient de
réviser à la baisse les recettes
fiscales nettes de l'état à hauteur
d'environ 700 millions d'euros
permettez moi de présenter cette
révision par grandes catégories de
recettes effet combiner mes amendements
1 5 76 138 408 ainsi que le rejet de
l'article 6 de ce projet de loi de
finances relatif aux revenus du capital
conduisent à devoir réviser à la baisse
les recettes nettes de l'impôt sur le
revenu à hauteur de 275 millions d'euros
les recettes de l'impôt sur les sociétés
se trouvent aussi minoré de 160 millions
d'euros
suite aux votes sur les amendements 9
activié bis et 143 les recettes de tva
doit également être revu à la baisse de
190 millions d'euros à la suite de
l'adoption 438 les recettes de la ti cpe
sont réduits d'un peu plus de 15
millions d'euros à la suite du vote de
l'amendement 436 les autres recettes
fiscales baisse de 60 millions d'euros
en conséquence des votes soit
déplafonnement de plusieurs recettes
affectées à des personnes autres que
l'état s'agissant ensuite des
prélèvements sur recettes leur montant
est mineur et de 4 millions d'euros
l'amendement numéro 6 a créé en effet un
nouveau prélèvement sur recettes
s'agissant maintenant des comptes
spéciaux leur sol des minerais de 15
millions d'euros
l'amendement l'article d'équilibré j'ai
donc l'honneur de vous présenter procède
enfin une modification technique des
plafonds de crédits et d'emplois de
l'état mesdames et messieurs à l'issue
de votre première délibération le
déficit budgétaire
si cet article d'équilibré était adoptée
serait donc porté à 61,9 milliards
d'euros soit une progression de 707
millions d'euros par rapport au texte
issu des débats à l'assemblée nationale
merci monsieur le président d'avoir
perdu présenter cet article équilibre
ainsi monsieur le ministre pour cette
présentation l'amendement 201 est
présentée par monsieur de montgolfier
oui merci messieurs présents monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit
d'un amendement qui était extrêmement
important puisque du sort de cet
amendement va dépendre tout simplement
le choix de notre groupe quand vos de la
première partie très concrètement tout
simplement oui tout simplement parce que
très concrètement nous proposons d'aider
le gouvernement allait plus vite dans
ses engagements de réduire les dépenses
nous considérons en effet que le
gouvernement a annoncé des milles 10
milliards d'euros d'économies
supplémentaires
et la question que nous nous posons à
travers cet amendement c'est pourquoi
attendre pourquoi attendre et par cet
amendement nous proposons tout
simplement de réduire de 10 milliards
d'euros les dépenses nettes du budget et
par conséquent d'améliorer autant le
solde alors pourquoi parce que nous
considérons que l'effort
d'assainissement des finances publiques
ne peut reposer exclusivement sur les
recettes et sur l'augmentation des
impôts et nous proposons ainsi de suivre
tout simplement les recommandations de
la cour des comptes en a parlé
la recommandation de la commission
européenne selon l'école sur lesquels
l'effort doit reposer pour moitié sur
les dépenses et pour moitié sur les
recettes et grâce à des amendements nous
promouvrons équilibré cet effort entre
20 milliards d'euros de recettes
fiscales supplémentaires et 20 milliards
d'euros de réduction de dépenses
je pense que cet effort est possible il
est possible parce que le gouvernement
ne considère d'ailleurs qui l'éleva le
faire lui-même il nous l'a très
récemment annoncé et il est
indispensable compte tenu de la
dégradation récente notre note
compte tenu également des annonces de
157 mille chômeurs supplémentaires
nous ne pouvons pas attendre la mise en
oeuvre de ces efforts supplémentaires de
réductions de dépenses
alors monsieur ministre voulait dire sur
quelles dépenses mais sur quelles
dépenses nous pouvons faire porter cet
effort de dix milliards supplémentaires
eh bien pour cela il faudra tout
simplement adopter cet amendement parce
que si cet amendement est adopté
nous serions amenés à nous abstenir sur
le vote de la première partie et ne
soyons donc amené à examiner la seconde
partie est dans le cadre des crédits
d'émission est bien souvent des
propositions très précises sur les
missions sur lequel nous feront porter
nos réductions de dépenses
alors bien sûr l amendement vient du
bonhomme vient d'être adopté et bien sûr
nous pouvons rectifié l'amendement mais
avant je dois t'en lui souhaite entendre
le ministre parce que il est très clair
que nous avons la ferme volonté de
proposer des mesures d'économies
supplémentaires
et pour ça il faudra évidemment de
petits cet amendement merci chers
collègues
alors monsieur rapporteur général l'avis
de la commission sur les deux
amendements d'abord celui du
gouvernement monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
ces deux amendements discussions
conjointes me conduit ce tas vous
indiquez dans un premier temps que
l'amendement présenté par le
gouvernement vise à récapituler
l'ensemble des dispositions qui ont été
votés avec l'accord ou sans l'accord du
rapporteur général et donc de la
commission des finances le ministre nous
indiquer que cela dégrade et le solde de
plus de 700 millions d'euros ce qui est
sans doute beaucoup vous en conviendrez
mais il s'agit effectivement d'un
amendement qui retrace la réalité des
votes et dans ces conditions bien sûr je
suis favorable puisque c'est un constat
c'est un monde constat de l'ensemble de
des éléments de changement du budget
s'agissant du second amendement celui
présenté par le groupe ump et que notre
collègue de montgolfier vient de vous
présenter bien entendu je suis d'un
autre avis puisque notre collègue vient
de nous dire nous préconisons 10
milliards d'économies de plus je ferai
simplement trois remarques
le gouvernement a souhaité que dans le
redressement des finances publiques nous
ayons une trajectoire qui pour
l'exercice 2013
le premier des cinq exercices à venir on
met d'abord l'accent sur les recettes et
que pour les dépenses en
fasse appel à des ogms des réductions de
dépenses dans les années à venir
pour une raison simple c'est que il faut
privilégier ce qui est le plus efficace
en matière de redressement économique et
de croissance
et l'effet de levier sur les recettes et
plus efficace que l'effet de levier sur
les baisses de dépenses comme on veut
tous augmenter la croissance je pense
qu'on ne peut que souscrire à cette
volonté du gouvernement d'améliorer la
croissance dans notre pays c'est raison
pour laquelle s'il y a un objectif de 50
50 sur les cinq ans parce que j'attire
votre attention sur le fait que le
déficit aujourd'hui de 81 milliards dans
notre pays c'est pas nous qui l'avons
créé nous savons d'où il vient et qui en
est responsable
eh bien il faudra que l'on atteigne des
économies et des recettes
supplémentaires de 80 milliards dans
cette trajectoire des cinq années et
dans ces conditions du gouvernement
s'engage sur 50 50 ce qui permettra
effectivement de faire autant appel aux
recettes et aux dépenses mais dans un
calendrier qui n'est pas tout à fait
celui que vous suggérez
la deuxième observation que je
souhaitais faire c'est que nous avons
sollicité depuis six jours que ce débat
a été engagé nous avons sollicité le
groupe ump quant à savoir où on allait
appliquer c'est 10 milliards d'économies
sur quel registre de dépenses on allait
procéder parce que chers collègues nous
avons eu une discussion en commission
depuis trois semaines sur tous ces
rapports successifs
ils ont été tous adoptés par la
commission sauf un ou deux et je n'ai
pas entendu mes chers collègues en
commission des finances
des propositions émanant du groupe ump
visant à trouver 10 milliards
d'économies j'ai rien entendu et aucune
proposition et aujourd'hui on découvre
tout d'un coup que on trouverait on
serait capable de trouver 10 milliards
d'un seul coup d'un seul simplement
parce que on a à justifier d'une posture
politique et que l'on doit mettre en
avant un slogan nous on est davantage
pour les économies mes chers collègues
je suis désolé vous êtes totalement
incapable de nous dire où quand comment
et dans ces conditions
l'amendement l'amendement n'est pas
sérieux
très honnêtement
nous sommes ici dans un débat projet
contre projet votre amendement n'est pas
sérieux convenait dans mes chers
collègues
et puis il ya une autre raison qui
renforce encore cette argumentation la
troisième raison c'est que depuis dix
ans depuis dix ans on nous a annoncé que
les programmes des différents
gouvernements qui se sont succédés
allait aboutir à de nombreuses économies
sur les dépenses
cela fait dix ans qu'on entend ça et en
moyenne au cours des dix années passées
les résultats qui ont été obtenus par
les majorités en place ont toujours été
moitié moindre que les prévisions qui
avaient été faites vous avez toujours
failli dans les réalisations par rapport
à ses ambitions que vous avez est allé
depuis dix ans face au pays
et c'est bien la raison pour laquelle il
y a eu je crois au vote des
présidentielles du printemps dernier une
sanction qui a conduit à considérer
effectivement qu'il ya vu une forme
d'inefficacité une incapacité à
redresser les finances publiques du pays
et ceux ci se trouvent aujourd'hui avéré
est constatée par tous et ce n'est pas
cette petite annonce que vous seriez
capable de trouver 10 milliards d'euros
d'économies en quelques heures
qui va changer la donne vous avez failli
dans votre mission de redressement des
finances publiques ce gouvernement est
courageux et a annoncé la couleur
il a annoncé la couleur il a annoncé la
couleur il se montre en capacité
d'assumer l'impopularité parce qu'il ya
toujours d'impopularité qu'on veut
redresser les finances publiques
et nous souhaitons l'accompagner dans
cet effort l'accompagner dans cette
ambition part parce qu'on sait très bien
que si les finances publiques ne sont
pas redressées et si on n'atteint pas
l'objectif annoncé
on sait très bien sûr qui sera retombée
ce sont les générations futures qui
seront davantage mises à contribution
il nous faut assumer aujourd'hui cet
effort de redressement
c'est ce qui est proposé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il nous faut
rejeter cet amendement deux façades
c'est du window dressing on ne peut pas
accepter cette façon de travailler et il
faut rejeter cet amendement
mieux c'est le sur accord général
monsieur le ministre la vie du
gouvernement sur l'amendement 200 merci
monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui traduit me semble-t-il un
fait peut-être surprenant et qui est que
la politique gouvernementale 2013 la
dépense publique rencontre l'assentiment
du parlement au delà des rangs stricte
de la majorité gouvernementale
si vous voulez faire des économies
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices de l'opposition c'est parce
que vous estimez qu'effectivement et
nous en sommes d'accord il n'est pas
possible de redresser nos finances
publiques
uniquement par un effort fiscal c'est
parce que nous faisons cette analyse que
dans la loi de finances pour 2013
nous proposons certes un relèvement des
recettes inévitable mais aussi des
économies 10 milliards d'euros pour le
budget de l'état 2,5 au titre de
l'assurance maladie
cet effort est donc jugée manifestement
insuffisant par le porte parole du
groupe ump et je trouve ce jugement peut
être un peu sévère
si l'on compare ce qu'est ce budget pour
2013 avec ce qui fut fait ces cinq
dernières années
quel que soit le critère que l'on
choisisse prenons ce qui s'est fait en
moyenne ces cinq dernières années
ces cinq dernières années l'évolution de
la dépense publique sous l' empire de la
majorité ump a été une évolution de
1,7 pour 1,3 pardon 7% 1,3 pour cent
pardonnez-moi dévolu sur la dépense
publique en moyenne
et chaque année les cinq années
précédentes c'était 2,3 nous proposons
une évolution des dépenses publiques de
0 6% en moyenne
et chaque année compte tenu des 10
milliards d'économies que nous serons
amenés à faire pour financer le plan
compétitivité
certes ça n'est qu'une attention mais
nous mettons en oeuvre cette intention
dès la première année budgétaire en
faisant cette économie de 10 milliards
d'euros
on peut aussi comparer ce que nous
faisons pour la première année pleine de
cette nouvelle mandature avec ce qui fut
fait pour la première année pleine de
mandature précédente car la loi de
finances initiale pour 2008 que mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs de l'ump vous
alliez voter j'ai l'imaginent en tout
cas pour ceux qui siégeaient dans cet
hémicycle cette loi de finances pour
2008 se décomposer de deux façons sur le
champ zéro valeur l'évolution de la
dépense fut de 1,5 pour cent
nous respectons zéro valeur et toutes
dépenses de l'état confondues nous
proposons une augmentation de la dépense
de 0 3%
la majorité ump de l'époque avait voté
une augmentation des dépenses de 3,3
pour cent soit plus de dix fois plus
donc que l'on compare en moyenne avec
les cinq années précédant duclos comparé
deux premières années à première année
il me semble que ce que ce gouvernement
et sa majorité gouvernementale s'apprête
à faire et me semble-t-il plus
appréciable plus efficace plus énergique
oui plus courageux merci monsieur le
rapporteur général d'avoir utilisé ce
terme plus courageux que ce qui fut fait
par ceux qui aujourd'hui nous demanderez
de l'être davantage me qui eux l'ont été
beaucoup moins et au nom de cela et même
si je comprends très bien les raisons
pour lesquelles cet amendement est
proposé au nom de cela je demande à la
majorité du sénat de rejeter cet
amendement tout en considérant les
efforts que le gouvernement demande au
parlement c'est-à-dire via le parlement
à nos concitoyens tout en considérant
que cet effort pour difficile et dur
qu'il soit est absolument nécessaire
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
probablement monsieur le président
lorsque je reprendrai la parole une fois
que le vote aura été émis
sur et ses amendements et cet article d'
équilibre technique
merci monsieur le ministre nous allons
voter sur le 442 rectifié explications
de vote monsieur de l'est sous le 440
nous sommes sur le 442 rectifié sur
l'amendement de monsieur de montgolfier
nous sommes sur l'amendement du
gouvernement
ah oui je peux faire l'explication de
vote façon pour les deux donc monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous ne sommes pas
favorables à la logique qui prévaut à
l'élaboration et la présentation de
cette loi de finances nous pensions que
le matraquage fiscal qui est proposé
est excessif il y a eu 7 milliards de
plus dap au mois de juillet dernier on
en propose 20 milliards dans ce dans
cette loi de finances a fait 27
milliards en très peu de temps et nous
pensons que l'économie française va en
subir de graves conséquences
nous ne sommes pas les seuls à le penser
puisque j'ai un article de jacques
attali là qui peut pas être soupçonné
d'être un affreux réactionnaire de
droite ou du centre est qui qui nous dit
qu'on peut on peut taxer les plus-values
et les revenus du capital comme le
travail c'est ce qui est proposé dans
cette loi de finances mais à condition
que les taux ne soit pas confiscatoire
or en france ils le sont personne ne
peut avoue avoir envie de travailler ni
choisir d'investir dans un pays qui lui
prend les deux tiers de ce qu'il gagne
par ses efforts ou ses investissements
si de tels taux sont mises en place la
france verra partir ces entrepreneurs
ses cadres et les centres de direction
des entreprises
et je crois que ce suicide fiscales y
est organisée dans cette loi de finances
et c'est pour ça que nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter et notre logique depuis
longtemps alors on peut parler
effectivement des cinq dernières années
on peut parler des dix dernières minutes
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est 2013 et
c'est les années à venir et nous pensons
que les efforts en dépenses doivent être
beaucoup plus important que ce qui est
proposé
vous nous dites 10 milliards c'est 10
milliards de non augmentation des
dépenses terre que vous le fait de ne
pas augmenter les dépenses vous
considérez que c'est des économies nous
pensons d'ailleurs comme le président de
la république il faut aller au delà
parce que le président de la république
dans une récente interview a dit qu'il
fallait 10 milliards de plus en 2013
donc ce qui est proposé aujourd'hui
c'est d'inscrire dès maintenant dans la
loi de finances ces dix milliards
supplémentaires
et moi je suis je suis convaincu que
c'est pendant quelques heures mais en
même quelques jours quelques semaines
nous allons trouver ces 10 milliards
dans le budget il ya de quoi faire dans
le budget de l'état il ya de quoi faire
dans le budget des opérateurs on l'a vu
hier avec le centre national du cinéma
sur lequel je suis sûr qu'on reviendra
dans l'est dans les mois et les années à
venir parce que je proposais de prendre
400 millions de récupérer 250 millions
la majorité du sénat ne l'a pas souhaité
mais
je pense qu'on aura à y revenir et il y
à d'autres opérateurs sur lesquels nous
avons aussi moyen de récupérer de
l'argent pour notre budget donc tout
tout ceci fait que moi je voterai
largement l'amendement de monsieur de
montgolfier et je souhaite que qu'il
soit adopté pour que l'on puisse
continuer ici au sénat à étudier
l'émission sur lesquels nous aurons
beaucoup de propositions à faire en
matière de réduction de la dépense
publique
si chaque collège même des égos pour
explication de vote
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans les
discussions qui entoure cet article
déquilibre la position des membres du
groupe ump doivent être étudiées en fait
à l'aune des décisions et des résultats
du précédent gouvernement
car entre les quelques décisions sur
lesquelles l'actuel gouvernement n'est
pas revenu en arrière et celle de son
prédécesseur il ya de grandes
différences qui se font déjà sentir
en effet l'objectif de réduction du
déficit public qui pour l'année 2010
avait été chiffré par le gouvernement à
7,7 pour cent du pib
il s'est finalement élevé à 7,1 pour
cent
ça c'est pas des prévisions sarret c'est
les chiffres réalisés
de la même manière le déficit public de
l'année 2011 s'est établi à 5,2 pour
cent du pib alors que l'objectif
prévisionnel était de 5,7 pour cent et
même 6% dans le programme de stabilité
de fin 2010 toujours pareil des chiffres
réalisés pas des prévisions la france
fut le seul pays de l'union européenne
qui dans le contexte de rebond de la
crise parvint à réduire son déficit
budgétaire de près d'un milliard d'euros
par rapport à la loi de finances
initiale et le déficit structurel fut
diminuer de près 2 points pour la
première fois alors ces chiffres
montrent mes chers collègues que le
précédent gouvernement savait tenir ses
engagements et cela malgré une crise
économique sans précédent crise
économique dont nous pouvons parler
puisque désormais les responsables
socialistes
anne
est enfin son existence après quatre
longues années de déni
autre symbole des engagements respectés
du précédent gouvernement
la baisse des dépenses de l'état qui
passèrent de 56,6 % du pib en 2010 à
55,9 % du pib en 2011 et en 2011 ce fut
la première fois depuis 1945 que les
dépenses de l'état diminuent r alors ce
qui nous différencie
monsieur le ministre c'est que messieurs
vous avez pris des chiffres sur cinq ans
incluant les dépenses liées au plan de
relance
bon moi j'ai pris des chiffres chaque
année et les chiffres réalisés c'est ce
qu'ils nous croient que c'est quand même
plus honnête
1 on est bien d'accord que il ya eu de
nombreuses années où les efforts ont été
insuffisants à gauche comme à droite
d'ailleurs
et donc moins ce que j'ai donné comme
résultat c'est vraiment les chiffres en
riant enregistrés et non pas les
prévisions mais on en reparlera à cela
on pourrait ajouter le respect de
l'ondam on notera aussi les résultats
pour l'année 2011 où les dépenses sont
estimées à 160 6,7 milliards d'euros
inférieur d'environ 400 millions d'euros
à l'objectif
en comparaison les chers collègues
quelles mesures ont été prises par le
gouvernement actuel
depuis que celui ci est aux
responsabilités ah oui on pense d'abord
à la hausse des allocations de rentrée
scolaire que l'on sait hélas ne peut ne
sont pas toujours utilisées par les
parents pour les frais des équipements
scolaires des enfants
ben oui mais c'est la vérité et il est à
ce titre regrettable que le gouvernement
n'ait pas pensé à se doter d'une petite
calculette un peu plus performante car
la hausse des effectifs aussi dans la
fonction publique et notamment les 65
mille postes promis par françois
hollande sur cinq ans va annihiler pour
moitié les efforts réalisés lors du
précédent quinquennat qui avait vu la
suppression de 150 2000 postes cette
décision qui n'a été l'exigence de
personnes va coûter à l'état 2,5
milliards d'euros soit le quart de
l'effort supplémentaire demandé aux
gouvernants
à cela vient s'ajouter les deux
milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires qu'elle lui
l'augmentation insignifiante du smic qui
se décompose en effet en 600 millions
d'euros pour les tambours ailleurs et
1,4 milliard d'euros d'allègements de
charges en plus sur les bas salaires
un coot très important pour une hausse
très faible de 6 euros 50 par mois
seulement hors inflation
pour les salariés qui touchent le smic
ce qui est bien peu de chose en barisone
la perte subie par l'arrêt de la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
là encore aucune urgence ne pouvait
justifier une telle mesure
dernier élément que je souhaite évoquer
pour mettre en lumière la promotion la
soi disant justice sociale mise en
application par l'actuel gouvernement
il ya la baisse de la tva pour certains
secteurs d'activité comme le livre et le
spectacle vivant
outre le fait que les professionnels de
ces secteurs soient de formidables
leaders d'opinion qu'il participe à la
vie associative et qu'il soit très
influente dans leur milieu
il n'y a aucune justification pour que
ces activités soient favorisés lorsque
toutes les autres doivent fournir des
efforts
c'est un exemple anecdotique ok mais
révélateur et c'est pour toutes ces
raisons pour ma part que je voterai en
faveur de l'amendement du groupe ump
excellemment bien présenté par albéric
de montgolfier
merci chocolat gagne la parole est un
monsieur de lège pour explication de
vote
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
bien entendu les explications du
rapporteur et du ministre par rapport à
l'amendement proposé par monsieur de
montgolfier vont vous dire que j'étais
assez étonné de l'argumentation qui
consiste à ne pas répondre sur la barre
demande de monsieur de montgolfier mais
à vous référer au passé
je suis d'autant plus étonné que je ne
peux pas oublier le nombre de fois où
vous avez reproché au gouvernement
précédent de ne pas dépenser plus
donc malvenu aujourd'hui de venir nous
expliquer que vous trouvez que la
situation de notre budget et son
déséquilibre ne serait pas tout à fait
ce que vous aviez imaginé cet amendement
ils expriment très clairement et il
était important qu'il soit présenté à
cet instant et l'expriment très
clairement que selon nous vous faites
fausse route
refusant à l'évidence ne vous attaquez à
la dépense et c'est ce qui est apparu
tout au long de cette discussion le
discours d'avant le 6 mai je voudrais le
rappeler taxons les riches et les
entreprises du cac 40
je note que vous ne tenez plus vous nous
parler maintenant de pacte de
compétitivité mais en attendant ce
budget 2013 et bien inspirés par ce
discours que vous avez oublié que
semble-t-il vous regrettez par moments
mais en tous les cas il en est la
traduction
je voudrais également noté que vous nous
expliquer on va augmenter les impôts
parce que au fond l'augmentation des
impôts c'est moins recife que la
diminution de la dépense d'abord ça
reste à prouver
mais je note que je note que le
rapporteur général nous a expliqué qu'
on allait sur une période sans doute
revenir un juste équilibre mais vous
fondez cet équilibre sur les prévisions
dont nous savons tous et vous les
premiers qu'elles sont peu réaliste et
quand j'entendais le rapporteur général
nous dire que nos prévisions ne sont pas
toujours réaliser je voudrais chers
collègues avec vous former à veux c'est
que les prévisions que vous avez inscrit
dans la loi de programmation budgétaire
se réaliseront parce qu'elle conditionne
effectivement le retour à l'équilibré et
nous savons d'ores et déjà que ses
prévisions sont fausses et que par
conséquent ce budget est tout à fait
apte à faire et donc je remercie
monsieur de montgolfier d'avoir présenté
cet amendement car effectivement il
marque il y a une différence entre vous
et nous nous nous pensons qu'il faut
s'attaquer aux dépenses et vous vous
continuez à penser que l'avenir est dans
la dépense publique
merci chers collègues la parole était
monsieur marini pour explication de vote
sur le président sur le ministre mes
chers collègues puisque les deux
amendements du gouvernement aidé albéric
de montgolfier sont en discussion
commune
je vais indiquer ma position sur l'année
sur l'autre s'agissant de l'amendement
du gouvernement
il reprend les votes intervenus il les
collectionne
et sachant que je me suis opposée comme
mon groupe à la plupart des articles qui
ont été votées il va de soi que je
voudrais contre cet amendement du
gouvernement même si les techniques car
ceci traduit on le comprendra une
opposition politique maintenant
l'amendement d'albe eric de montgolfier
j'y suis favorable même s'il ne détaille
pas de manière précise
l'imputation de l'économie mais non non
non ce n'est pas eric doligé c'est
jérôme cahuzac
car monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous dire pouvez vous me
dire mais laissez moi je vous en prie
aller au bout de ma question c'est une
question que j'adresse au ministre du
budget et je lui demande monsieur le
ministre
pouvez-vous me regarder dans les yeux
n'est ce pas et pouvez-vous et pouvez
vous me dire que l'année prochaine
au cours de l'année 2013 vous ne serez
pas amené à proposer la même économie et
je m'explique
l'année prochaine la croissance est ce
qu'elle sera de 0 8% l'année prochaine
est ce qu'il ne faudra pas inspirer
confiance et aux agences de notation et
aux marchés et à tous les investisseurs
est ce que ça ne nécessitera pas de
devoir faire des efforts
l'année prochaine
monsieur cahuzac est-ce que vous ne
serez pas contraints de venir avec un
deuxième collectif budgétaire
puisqu'il y en a un premier qui est déjà
annoncé pour nous proposer des économies
budgétaires
et là c'est vous qui boirait la potion
amère et c'est vous qui répartira les
économies mission par mission et ce sera
votre devoir de le faire alors nous
n'anticipons qu'un tout petit peu avec
l'amant demande albéric de montgolfier
et il est tout à fait naturel que nous
le votons merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur fortassin pour
explication de vote
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
assistons un mouvement intéressant
d'un côté un numéro théâtrale d'autres
volets de la part du président de la
commission des finances
et puis un numéro de prestidigitation
fabuleux de monsieur de montgolfier
sorte david copperfield de la finance
qui est tendre l2 nous d'essayer de nous
faire oublier que vous étiez aux
responsabilités alors évidemment pendant
cette période
pratiquement la dette abyssale a doublé
et en plus vous avez eu la théorie
facile du cadeau fiscal
on est même arrivé à ce qui peut
apparaître comme pittoresque à savoir
que des gens qui avaient déjà payé leurs
impôts ont les armes pour c est ce que
vous pouvez me citer parmi ceux là
l'un d'entre eux qui est emprunté pour
payer les impôts certainement pas et
puis de grâce que vous savez très bien
que
quand on exerce des responsabilités
la première des responsabilités à avoir
c'est de voter les recettes car en
définitive n'importe quel de nos
concitoyens au café du commerce est
capable de vous dire qu'il faut payer
dans les dépenses
c'était incontestablement très facile et
on fait on a un effet de non pas de
surprise mais face à l'auditoire qui est
toujours très apprécié mais je ne
voterai pas bien entendu cet amendement
car après tout le courage c'est de voter
les dépenses les recettes et de voir
comment on peut bien sûr ensuite au
mieux faire en sorte que les dépenses ne
soient pas excessives mais ne pas
tailler comme cela de façon arbitraire
ça ne mord pas nécessairement des gens
qui par ailleurs sont particulièrement
estimable merci chers collègues ma part
le thème ce doligé pour explication de
vote
oui malheureusement je n'ai pas trouvé
les 10 milliards comme ça rapidement
mais je voudrais quand même faire un
certain nombre de remarques alors
effectivement on ne ressort toujours la
sanction du mois de mai est
effectivement s'ils n'avaient pas eu la
sanction du mois de mai vous ne seriez
pas majoritaires ici ou ailleurs et donc
non mais on l'acceptent ceci étant ceci
étant je vous ferai remarquer que s'il y
a eu cette sanction mois de mai c'est
peut-être parce qu'il ya eu énormément
de promesses qui ont été faites et qu'en
ce moment vous n'êtes pas en train de
les tenir et je veux vous permet de
regarder toute la liste des promesses
qui ont été faites par le candidat et
vous pourrez cochet celles qui ne sont
pas tenues et les marches arrières que
vous faites
deuxièmement monsieur marc nous nous
reproche en commission des finances nous
dit bas toutes les missions ont été
votés ben oui l'émission été voté par la
majorité je vous ferai remarquer que
vous êtes majoritaires et qu'à chaque
fois qu'on fait des propositions
d'amendements elle ne passe pas donc
vous êtes majoritaires c'est le fait
majoritaire dont vous venez pas nous
reprocher que l'émission était été votée
je vous rappellerai aussi
lorsque nous étions majoritaires je n'ai
pas vu une seule fois où vous n'ayez pas
demandé sur des missions des
augmentations de crédits et de dépenses
systématiquement vous n'avez jamais
cherché l'année dernière l année d'avant
quand on essayait de faire des économies
à nous aider à faire des économies
donc c'est quand même une situation
assez particulière que de nous reprocher
certaines positions alors monsieur
montgolfier nous propose 10 milliards
d'économies
je vous rappellerai que monsieur le
ministre nous a dit à quelques instants
où je crois monsieur le rapporteur les
10 milliards d'économies que nous serons
amenés à faire vous ne dites pas ou quoi
et comment vous nous faites une masse
globale de 10 milliards d'économies et
vous nous dites vous venez de sortir 10
milliards je vous rappellerai que l'on a
eues dans les quinze jours qui ont
procédé est là david copperfield
effectivement se pouvait peut-être
s'appliquer le rapport gallois il est
quand même arrivé du jour au lendemain
et on nous a proposé un certain nombre
de dispositions nouvelles du jour au
lendemain
en ce qui concerne la tva on nous a
annoncé qu'il n'y aurait pas de hausse
de tva et du jour au lendemain on nous a
annoncé une hausse de tva
il me semble monsieur le ministre qu'un
jour lorsque vous étiez une audition et
c'était il ya pas si longtemps que ça
en commission des finances derrière la
petite table avec le tapis vert on vous
avait posé la question est ce qu'il y
aura une hausse de tva et vous nous
aviez non non non il y aura pas de
hausse de tva
huot non en commission des finances oui
huit jours après on nous annonçait
qu'ils auraient une commission une
hausse de 2 de tva qui arriverait
prochainement à 6 donc elle va arriver
bon donc finalement vous nous annoncez
sans arrêt des nouveautés qui n'étaient
pas prévus à l'origine dans nos
premières discussions et des charges
nouvelles et des prélèvements nouveaux
nous nous vous proposons de faire en
sorte de faire des économies et je pense
qu'il ya des économies sérieux à faire
si l'on veut regarder de près un certain
nombre de budgets capacités comme vous
regardez les décisions qui sont prises
aux non nationaux au niveau national et
que l'on applique aux collectivités je
pense au département transmet dans bien
d'autres domaines où tout ce qui attrait
pour rémunération est décidée au niveau
national on doit les appliquer au niveau
local tout ce qui a trait aux
prestations est décidé au niveau
national et on doit l'appliquer au
niveau local on n'a pas la possibilité
de faire en sorte que les prestations
sont pas forcément tout à fait les mêmes
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
dans un certain nombre de domaines
je vous rappelle que quelqu'un qui
touchent le rsa à paris a certainement
beaucoup plus de difficultés que celui
qui touche le rsa en province dans un
certain nombre de départements donc
probablement qu'il y à des économies à
faire au niveau d'un certain nombre de
collectivités et sur lesquelles on
pourrait travailler dans les mois à
venir ou dans les semaines à venir pour
contribuer ou 10 milliards d'économies
donc la proposition qui a été faite par
notre collègue albéric de montgolfier
est une proposition qui est tout à fait
réaliste et raisonnable et nous vous
demandons de pouvoir y travailler si
vous êtes d'accord mais à priori vous
avez dit que vous n'étiez pas d'accord
c'est dommage parce que on aurait on se
serait abstenu et ça aurait permis
d'aller plus loin que vous faire un
certain nombre de propositions
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur foucault pour explication de
vote
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
depuis depuis le début de la session et
depuis le début de la discussion
les parlementaires du groupe crc des
parlementaires responsables ont formulé
un certain nombre de propositions que je
ne vais pas évidemment rappeler ici
la discussion s'est faite mais la ligne
2 de ses propositions elle était connue
d'avancé
il fallait de la recette des recettes
supplémentaires pour pouvoir justement
avancer de façon progressistes face aux
problèmes que connaît notre pays
alors à partir de là à partir de ces
propositions
mais à partir aussi mes chers collègues
de l'excellent travail qui avait été
accompli ici même l'an dernier pas la
majorité de gauche au sénat constitué de
notre avis constituer la base de cette
démarche une démarche porteuse
d'évolution structurelles fondamentales
des recettes de l'état en vue de définir
les contours d'une loi de finances
audacieuse d'une loi de finances
porteuse d'une dépense publique riche
mais riche d'un pull sion économique et
bien sûr riche de croissance je ne vais
pas revenir sur l'article 6 sur ce
milliard perdu je ne vais pas revenir
sur lies f avec ses 900 millions de
paires du cher collègue
l'année dernière vous avez proposé une
série de mesures portant sur
l'imposition des sociétés dont le
produit attendu est de 8 milliards
d'euros
mais souvenons nous souvenez-vous la
majorité de gauche du sénat avait défini
l'an dernier une réforme de liesse
rapportant 20 milliards que nous avions
fait ensemble 20 milliards que cela a
rapporté d'euros dont en particulier à
un projet sur la part de financement des
entreprises
réalisé en commun voilà ce que nous
avons dit pendant cette première partie
de la loi de finances respectons ce sur
quoi nous nous étions engagés et je ne
vous ferai pas le grief de citer des
noms ici ou l'année dernière certains
disaient la règle d'or mais c'est pas
possible
même la commission européenne n'en veut
pas
autre qui disait 3% les 3% arrivé à 3%
du déficit ce n'est pas possible et nous
citer destexhe deux journaux et des
rapports d'économistes voilà mes chers
collègues pour ne pas pour ne pas avoir
été au bout du gué pour ne pas avoir été
en haut au bout de cette démarche
nous voici aujourd'hui face à un texte
qui justement un texte à force de
s'arrêter au milieu du gué fini par se
noyer et se noyer dans les eaux troubles
da équilibre budgétaire précaire et on
en est à écouter la droite qui a mis le
pays dans l'état que l'on connaît parce
que en même temps mes chers collègues
nos propositions qui ont été rejetées
l'ont été par le gouvernement mais l'ont
été aussi par la droite
cette droite qui a amené le pays dans
l'état dans lequel il est cette loi
sénatoriale qui a voté vous le savez ce
qu'est la beauté
ces dernières années je dirais une
droite restait comme allez les gars là
mêmes qui continue et qui a continué qui
encore là continue dans l'amendement qui
est présentée par monsieur de
montgolfier qui continuent contre
l'égalité devant l'impôt et contre la
dépense publique et à monsieur marini le
président de la commission finances qui
part de potion amère mais qui a fait
boire la potion amère au peuple de
france
si ce n'est cette droite et la politique
de droite qui a engendré les méfaits que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui dans notre pays
alors quand on redonne quand on redonne
sept cents oui mais je peux je peux vous
le savez quand on redonne
750 millions d'euros aux pigeons quand
on donne 300 millions aux groupes du btp
concessionnaires de programme ppp
quand 900 millions aux contribuables
dolly sf évidemment ensuite évidemment
ensuite mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre il ne reste plus beaucoup
il ne reste plus beaucoup d espace pour
le reste alors je vous dis et je termine
là dessus monsieur le ministre
sauf sauf évolution sens si nous ne
pourront évidemment pas en voté cet
amendement de récapitulation merci chers
collègues je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe ump sur
l'amendement 442 rectifié du
gouvernement je vous rappelle que la vie
de de la commission est favorable il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront secrétaire un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre en
métro un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettra un
bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
et
non
mais personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
j'invite mesdames et messieurs les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
nouveau
m
oui
l'affairé
résultat du scrutin numéro 47 sur
l'amendement numéro 4 142 rectifié
l'article 45 nombre de votants 338
nombre de suffrages exprimés
318 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 160 pour l'adoption 155 contre
163 le sénat n'a pas adopté
nous allons donc voter sur l'amendement
201 pas d'autres demandes d'explications
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre va bien
levé la main l'amendement n'est pas venu
je vais mettre voir l'article
d'équilibré avant de vous faire voter
sur cet article
je voudrais vous rappeler qu'il y ait en
réalité de vote
le premier sur l'article d'équilibré et
le second sur la première partie
si le sénat n'adopte pas l'article
d'équilibré il ne pourra pas sauf
demande de seconde délibération portant
sur cet article
voté en faveur de la première partie en
effet en application de la loi organique
et comme l'a précisé le conseil
constitutionnel la première partie doit
avoir été adoptée en sel de ses
dispositions qui constitue sa raison
d'être et il en est ainsi de l'article
qui arrêtent en recettes et en dépenses
les données général de l' équilibre il
s'agit donc d'un vote de cohérence en
revanche si le sénat adopte l'article
d'équilibré il pourra se prononcer
pleinement pour ou contre la première
partie y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote monsieur adnot
monsieur le président peut-être
peut-être j'ai pas bien suivi mais le
vote précédent
c'était bien le vote sur l'amendement du
gouvernement qui tirait les conséquences
d'un certain nombre de choses et il n'a
pas été adopté si l'amendement du
gouvernement n'est pas adoptée il ya
plus d'articles déquilibre donc
j'aimerais qu'on m'explique
en tout cas je voudrais vous dire mon
sentiment sur le l'article 45
je voudrais que personne ne préjuge de
ma position par rapport à l'ensemble de
ce projet de loi de finances mais je
considère que le sénat s'il ne
poursuivait pas la discussion jusqu'à
son terme serait en dehors de ses
responsabilités il me paraît absolument
nécessaire que
sans obligatoirement dire que nous
sommes d'accord avec ces différentes
choses mais quand même l'article
d'équilibré il tire les conséquences des
différents votes vous avez obtenu ici
avec un peu de là bas la suppression de
certains articles qui vous déplaisent et
alors maintenant on voudrait pas
l'article d' équilibre pour pouvoir
continuer la discussion
je pense qu'il faut être cohérent moi
aussi quelqu'un dans mon budget me
disais au milieu du gué ben non on
n'adopte pas les recettes et comme ça on
discute pas de ce qu'on va faire dans le
budget et on pourrait pas conduire les
affaires et ben je pense qu'aucun
d'entre vous dans aucune de coupe vos
collectivités vous n'accepteriez que ça
se passe comme ça et donc moi je pense
que sans partager ce qui a été décidé
nous devons au moins nous abstenir pour
laisser se poursuivre la discussion
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe ump sur l'article
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par atik 56
du règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter
pour remettront secrétaire un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
promettront un bulletin bleu ce qui soit
s'abstenir métro un bulletin rouge le
scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
est ouvert
m
l'article suspension
à tout à l'heure
je
lol de vieux avec
le vent
vous me direz vous
le personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin clôt j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
c'est vrai
ok
plus
dans l'avion
je voudrais terminer
je crois plus que
d
je
nous quittons un instant l'hémicycle du
sénat cet amendement aura donc été
rejetée je suis à côté de jean arthuis
sénateur union centriste de l'ust et de
la mayenne bonsoir alors la séance a été
suspendue car le gouvernement je vous le
disais au début de cette séance et bien
demande une deuxième intervention sur
l'article 6 qui concernait et bien la
taxation des plus values sur les
cessions d'entreprises un mouvement est
bien qu'une taxe qui avait été dénoncée
par les entrepreneurs autres programmes
et pigeons est ce que c'est une bonne
chose de demander un second vote sur cet
article 6 qui avait été retoquée par le
sénat jean arthuis le gouvernement dans
un premier temps à tirer les
conséquences des vote du sénat est
proposé une nouvelle présentation de
l'article d'équilibré
mais cet article rectifiez a été rejeté
par le sénat
par conséquent on se retrouve avec
l'article d'équilibré tel qu'il
résultait des votes de l'assemblée
nationale mais qui ne correspond pas au
vote du sénat au vote sur les recettes
sur les articles de la première partie
et donc on est là dans une situation qui
est complètement bancal c'est clair
alors le gouvernement utilise ses
prérogatives qui montre bien les limites
du parlement en france c'est à dire qu'
il va demander la correction de tous ces
articles que les sanaa avait voté contre
l'avis du gouvernement pour établir le
texte que souhaite le gouvernement
et ceci dans un vote bloqué c'est à dire
que c'est à prendre ou à laisser
ça passe ou ça casse et pourtant à quoi
ça va servir de demander une seconde
délibération sur tous ces articles quand
on sait que peut-être d'ici deux heures
et bien les sénateurs vont rejeter la
première partie du plf enfin du moins la
partie recettes
je pense pour le gouvernement l'occasion
de manifester sa détermination
que va-t-il se passer je n'en sais rien
peut-être que le gouvernement appelle sa
majorité potentielle mais je ne sais pas
comment vont réagir les représentants du
groupe du groupe communiste et citoyen
rhin on rappelle qu'il s'abstienne il ya
encore des espoirs selon vous qu'il
change d'avis non pas content mais j'ai
quand même l'impression qu'ils sont
déterminés à s'abstenir de faire des
sénateurs centristes ont voté contre la
première partie donc la partie recettes
vous faites partie de ceux qui allaient
vous abstenir
vous auriez souhaité que la discussion
aille à son terme ici au sénat oui mais
comme
le gouvernement a manifesté une franche
hostilité à l'idée de réduire le niveau
des crédits de dépenses je vais voter
contre l'article d'été libre mon groupe
s'est réuni hier est très
majoritairement a souhaité voter contre
parce que c'est un matraquage fiscal et
à titre personnel je dois dire que je
regrette beaucoup
au moment où le chômage explose que les
mesures de compétitivité n'est pas été
inscrite dès l'origine dans ce projet de
loi de finances pour 2013 et que ce que
l'on va voir demain ou après demain
c'est à dire un crédit d'impôt très
compliqué avec un allègement de 10
milliards seulement
tout cela est très en deçà de ce qu'il
faudrait mettre en oeuvre pour susciter
un choc de compétitivité et re créer
suffisamment d'emplois
si la seconde partie consacrée aux
dépenses n'est pas examinée par les
sénateurs parce qu'il a un risque bien
que la réserve parlementaire ne soit pas
votée très franchement je ne crois pas
on a vu des situations identiques dans
le passé gouvernement prendra ses
responsabilités en tout cas cette
l'agitation de ceux de sète cravache ou
je ne sais pas quelle menace est
dérisoire je dirais que c'est pas ça qui
détermine nos votes
je vous remercie et jean arthuis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci pour vos
éclairages vous allez donc en commission
car je vous rappelle que la commission
des finances s'est réuni à la demande de
son président philippe marini le
gouvernement a donc demandé une seconde
délibération sur cet article 6 qui
concernait la taxation des plus values
des cessions d'entreprises nous y
reviendrons bien entendu dans notre
édition de 19 heures et dès que la
séance reprend nous vous ferons vivre
bien entendu en direct le vote de ce
projet de loi de finances à tout à
l'heure